[Music]
Australians call them runners the
British know them as trainers Americans
refer to them as tennis shoes or
sneakers whatever you call them these
rubber-soled casual shoes are worn by
billions of people around the world
originally invented in the late 19th
century these simple canvas and rubber
creations have changed a lot since they
first hit the pavement
today sneaker consumption is at an
all-time high
no country buys more sneakers than the
United States where people purchase
three pairs a year on average to meet
this demand roughly twenty three billion
shoes are produced each year mostly in
factories across China and Southeast
Asia but making shoes has become more
complicated more labor-intensive and in
some ways more dangerous for the workers
involved and for our planet shoe
manufacturing accounts for roughly
one-fifth of the fashion industry's
carbon emissions sneakers alone generate
313 million metric tons of carbon
dioxide every year which is equivalent
to the annual emissions of 66 million
cars to better understand your shoes
carbon footprint let's dive into the
anatomy of a sneaker for starters the
heel insole midsole and upper layer are
usually made from synthetic textiles
like polyester nylon latex and
polyurethane mining the fossil fuels
that make up these materials emits tons
of greenhouse gases and processing those
raw ingredients into synthetic textiles
also uses a lot of energy further
compounding that pollution some sneaker
tops are made from natural sources like
leather but tanning this material relies
on chromium a carcinogenic chemical that
can damage freshwater ecosystems the
outer soles of most shoes are made of
rubber that's gone through a process
called vulcanization this technique adds
sulphur to superheated raw rubber to
create a material that's both elastic
and
until recently sneakers used natural
rubber for this process but today most
outer soles are made with a synthetic
blend of natural rubber and byproducts
from coal and oil producing these
materials accounts for 20% of a sneakers
carbon footprint but more than
two-thirds of the shoes carbon impact
comes from the next step
manufacturing a typical sneaker is
comprised of 65 discrete parts each of
which is produced by specialized
machinery
this means it's cheaper for factories to
mass-produce each piece separately
rather than manufacturing every part
under one roof but the transportation
required to ship these pieces to one
assembly plant emits even more co2 once
the components arrive at the assembly
line they undergo cutting pouring
melting baking cooling and gluing before
the final products can be stitched
together the Assembly of a typical
sneaker requires more than 360 steps and
accounts for the remaining 20% of a
sneakers environmental impact the
dispersion of factories fuels another
problem as well labor abuse most brands
don't own or operate their factories so
the plants they work with are in
countries with little to no worker
protection laws as a result many
laborers earn below the living wage and
are exposed to harmful chemicals like
toxic glue fumes when manufacturing is
complete the shoes are packaged and
transported to stores around the globe
for many these shoes could last years
but for someone running 20 miles a week
a pair of running shoes will start
wearing out after roughly six months
since the shoes are made of so many
different materials they're almost
impossible to break down into recyclable
components
20% of these shoes are incinerated while
the rest are tossed into landfills where
they can take up to 1,000 years to
degrade so how can we balance our love
of sneakers with the need for
sustainability first designers should
streamline design elements and focus on
eco-friendly materials factories need to
develop energy efficient manufacturing
processes that consolidate steps and
sneaker parts and consumers should
support companies using clean energy and
ethical manufacturing processes we can
also buy fewer shoes wear them for
longer and donate those we no longer
need so no matter what your style we can
all take steps towards a sustainable
future so that's the life story of your
average sneaker but what about smart
phones what's under that beautifully
engineered exterior and where did all
those little parts come from learn more
with this video
[Music]